♪ organ music playing ♪
Hello everyone!
To first-year, transfer, and
Eli Whitney students:
Welcome to Yale!
I also extend a warm welcome
to all the family members
and friends who
join me in recognizing this
milestone in your lives.
Today we begin
a new academic year
at a time of
significant upheaval.
Historically, social conflict
and disease pandemics
have catalyzed change.
And so we should not be
surprised that many are
calling now for further
transformation of our society.
We are dealing with two
parallel crises:
The COVID-19 pandemic
and the racial
inequality and injustice
rooted in our country's
history of slavery and
still facing us today.
We have all been affected by
these challenges,
especially members of the Black
and brown communities who bear
the brunt of these burdens
I have been giving a lot of
thought to the university's role
in addressing
difficult social issues.
Much remains to be answered
in this turbulent period,
but what is certain is that the
core mission of Yale is
more relevant than ever.
I am sure each of you
has studied Yale's
mission statement:
Yale is comitteded to
improving the world today
and for future generations
through outstanding research
and scholarship, education,
preservation, and practice.
Yale educates aspiring leaders
worldwide who serve all
sectors of society.
We carry out
this mission through the
free exchange of ideas
in an ethical, interdependent,
and diverse community
of faculty, staff,
students, and alumni.
Research, scholarship,
education, preservation,
and practice are vital
to understanding our past,
building on
hard earned progress,
identifying what
still needs to be done,
and creating change.
You know this;
It is why you are here.
You will be studying with
professors who use their
knowledge and expertise
to improve the world.
Yale faculty members work with
government officials and others
on containing the spread
of infectious diseases,
mitigating health disparities,
transforming policing,
and reforming the
criminal justice system.
While addressing challenges
like these, you will learn
from your teachers
how to analyze problems,
think critically,
and communicate clearly.
Along the way,
you will also be encouraged
to focus on yourself.
Whether fighting a
global pandemic or
the scourge of racism,
global climate change
or economic recession,
we must be willing to be
honest about our own motivations
and open to changing our minds.
Efforts to solve
pressing problems
will not be effective
if they are led by individuals
who cannot feel compassion
nor learn to cooperate,
nor by those who try to achieve
change through manipulation,
coercion, or brute force.
Yale's faculty understands this.
I recently discussed compassion
with Sterling Professor of
Sociology Elijah Anderson.
He has contributed immensely to
the study of racial inequality,
particularly in urban settings,
but he also has put his
expertise into practice
as a consultant to the
White House and to Congress.
I asked him,
how does he teach students who
want to improve the world?
He told me that he shows his
students how to see the world
from the point of view of others
how to have empathy.
Such an ability, he noted,
can help us to be
better scholars and students,
to be more sensitive to the
human condition, and to
be more self-aware.
When we are
motivated by empathy,
compassion, and cooperation,
we can bridge differences,
learn to understand one another,
and enact meaningful,
sustainable change.
Empathy and compassion,
a willingness to engage those
with whom we may not see
eye-to-eye
and a concern for the
misfortunes of others,
are preconditions
for cooperation.
Cooperation, working together
to solve a common problem,
especially one that we cannot
overcome by working alone,
requires us to listen to
each other charitably,
appreciate
each other's perspective,
and inhibit our desire to
dismiss individuals
with whom we initially believe
we cannot develop
common purpose.
The enemies of
compassion and cooperation
are fear and anger.
Now I'm not saying that it is
inappropriate to experience
the fear caused by a pandemic of
a novel virus that can be fatal.
And I'm not saying that one
shouldn't feel anger,
indeed, outrage,
at the killing of George Floyd
by former officers of the
Minneapolis police department.
In fact, COVID-19
makes me anxious;
and those former officers,
who took a sworn oath to
protect the public,
they leave me livid.
But although such fear
and anger can be motivating,
I must ensure that they do not
prevent my finding common ground
with well-meaning others
whose approaches to social
challenges are not
the same as mine.
I must engage them rather than
attempt to silence them
to accomplish anything
real and lasting.
Let me provide an
example from politics.
At one time,
women who became pregnant
and men who wanted to take time
off from work to care for
an infant
were at risk of being
fired by their employers.
But in 1993,
the U.S. Senate passed the
Family and Medical Leave Act,
guaranteeing family members the
ability to take a
prolonged unpaid leave
without risking their jobs in
order to tend to a newborn,
adopt a child,
or assist a sick family member.
How did this act,
which was considered revolutionary
at the time, pass?
Well, it was
developed cooperatively
by Senator Ted Kennedy,
among the most liberal
of lawmakers,
and Senator Orrin Hatch,
among the most conservative.
They opposed one another
on many policies,
but in this case, they found
a common cause:
supporting families.
They both felt compassion toward
individuals at risk for losing
their jobs due to childbirth,
and, perhaps more important,
they respected each other
as individuals,
listened to each other,
and placed national interest
ahead of party differences.
Their cooperation led,
ultimately, to significant
social change.
One final thought
about the importance of
compassion and cooperation:
Most of you, members of the
Class of 2024,
are part of Generation Z,
the post-millennials.
I am, well, a Baby Boomer.
Perhaps you have heard that you
and I are quite different.
True, you are the
first “digital natives"
and the only world
you have ever known
has included the smartphone,
texting, and social media.
And you are distinctive
in other ways as well.
Yours is the most racially and
ethnically diverse generation
in American history,
and you also promise
to be the best educated.
But it is not only that we are
different in these ways;
we also are said to disagree.
We are told we have different
views on politics,
music, and work.
I am sure you are familiar with
the stereotypes that
exaggerate our differences.
And stereotyping is another
barrier to compassion
and cooperation.
For example, you fault my
generation for the great
problems of our time.
And my generation too often
fails to understand you.
We pass you on the sidewalk,
mystified by your earbuds
and your clothes.
We tell you to grow up,
to get off social media,
to develop some
real-life coping skills,
and to get out of your parents'
basements and get a job.
And to us you say,
“OK, Boomer”
Thanks to an article I read in
the Wall Street Journal,
a print edition of it, in fact,
I am told this is a
“sly linguistic weapon
of intergenerational warfare."
Well, although such stereotypes
give rise to internet memes and
other kinds of clickbait to get
us to think of our differences
as “intergenerational warfare,"
we are not at war.
Those are distractions,
and they won't help us link
arms in overcoming
what might be standing in
the way of our future,
our shared future.
At the heart of "OK, Boomer" is
the belief that my generation
contributed to the serious,
even existential,
problems in the world that you
will enter and lead.
Your generation sees the
challenges posed by
climate change, disease,
abusive policing, war,
racism, and poverty.
You recognize the
urgency of these problems.
But my generation does as well.
Instead of dismissing one
another's perspectives and
focusing only on difference,
we need to direct our attention
to creating something better
for all who will follow us.
We can only do that
by harnessing our compassion
and cooperating.
Here at Yale,
we learn from each other.
That is why academics like me
enjoy spending their entire
lives on college campuses.
And it is why you
chose to come to Yale.
The passing of knowledge and
the responsibility to
do some good with it
from one generation to the next
is a large part
of Yale's mission.
It is hard work.
So, please:
use your time at Yale wisely.
Let us devote ourselves to
learning together,
to the personal transformation
that the pursuit of knowledge
can create for each of us.
Let us use these college years
to change ourselves,
to become more
compassionate human beings.
And then let us
work cooperatively
on existing and
emerging challenges
to create the world we desire.
Welcome to Yale!